ladies and gentlemen it's absolutely
wonderful to be here today you'll
probably be able to detect from my
accent that I spent much of my childhood
growing up in Africa and one of the
things which I love about Africa one of
the many things which I love about
Africa is Africans they love to tell
stories and if you think about it that's
how we have communicated since the
beginning of time that's how we have
connected since the beginning of time
it's by telling stories and so what I
want to do today is I want to tell you
three short stories three short stories
from three places which I know very very
well and which I think are going to have
a very big impact on every single person
in this room so would you come with me
now because I want to take you to the
first place I want to take you high up
into the Arctic to a place called
Spitsbergen now Spitsbergen is on the
edge of the Arctic sea Isis in the
Norwegian Arctic back in 2005 I went to
the Norwegian Arctic to undertake my
first very very cold
long-distance swim in 2005 the water
temperature there was 3 degrees
centigrade I went back there last year
and the water was no longer 3 degrees
centigrade the water was now 10 degrees
centigrade so the water had gone from 3
degrees to 10 degrees in just 12 years
and what scientists are telling us now
is very very clear what they are saying
is that within the next 12 years
they're expecting there to be very
little sea ice left in the Arctic in the
summer months so if you were a child
entering school right now when you leave
school in 12 years time you're going to
be entering a world which is very very
different to the world in which you
started your schooling right now what is
happening in the Arctic what is
happening to the north of us is going to
be impacting every single person on this
planet every single future generation
and the whole of
the animal kingdom let me take you now
from the Arctic all the way down to the
bottom of the world down to Antarctica
on the edge of Antarctica is an
incredible group of islands
it's called South Sandwich Islands and
when you arrive there it's like you have
arrived literally into a Polar Garden of
Eden over all the beaches are these
amazing penguins thousands and thousands
of penguins in the water these whales
coming up out of the sea and gorging
krill and you'll also see these enormous
great elephant seals some of them as big
as 3 tons coming out of the water
lumbering out of the water in order to
fight in order to mate ladies and
gentlemen there's a reason why Sir David
Attenborough covered the South Sandwich
Islands with so much detail in Blue
Planet 2 and the reason is because these
islands are unique and they are very
very precious then we leave the South
Sandwich Islands and then we come back
here to the United Kingdom back here to
the English Channel so I've just done
the swim from Dover I mean from Lands
End
all the way to Dover it was an enormous
swim it took me 49 days it was a
toughest swim I've ever done in my whole
life I started at Lands End and then I
swam from Lands End
all the way along the Cornish beaches
then to Plymouth where I grew up as a
young boy accross slime Bay around the
bottom of the Isle of whites past the
Seven Sisters around Dungeness and then
finally finally the Seven Sisters and
then finally the White Cliffs of Dover
it took me 49 days and what struck me
about this swim was two things the first
thing that struck me was just how
incredibly beautiful the coastline is
here in the United Kingdom it's
incredibly beautiful but the second
thing was struck me was how little
wildlife I saw I saw so many jellyfish I
mean they're a function of the fact now
that our waters are warming and also the
facts
that there now is so much overfishing so
their numbers of blooming I had the
jellyfish sting me in the face
underneath the armpits in the groin
absolutely everywhere okay but the other
thing was that I just saw a few Birds
I saw a few dolphins in Lyme Bay
I saw one turtle one turtle of Portland
and very little else and that was in 49
days and every beach I went to every
single beach I just saw this plastic
everywhere it's like we've hoovered up
the fish and we thrown in the plastic
and that is why it is so exciting that
the announcement that the United Kingdom
made last week now there was a lot of
stuff happening last week so you may
have missed it but the United Kingdom
made this announcement that they are
calling on all nations in the world all
nations to come together now to protect
at least 30 percent of our oceans now to
protect it by 2030 this is a huge
breakthrough I've come here today to
thank you very very much but there's a
rub to this and that is that you also
have to get your own house in order it
will be impossible for the United
Kingdom to lead on ocean conservation
which I think it should do but it'll be
impossible to do it unless you also have
your own home in order around the United
Kingdom in the waters around the United
Kingdom you have only fully protected
just seven square kilometres I mean just
think about it I mean it's shocking said
only seven square kilometers of the
waters around the United Kingdom are
fully protected let me just give you an
example of how this plays out at the end
of the English Channel is an incredible
iconic landmark it's called Goodwin
Sands and on Goodwin Sands this is where
all the seals come up this is a place
where they're endangered eels and lots
of birds and so your government has set
this area side now as a new potential
what you call a marine conservation zone
but at the same time you also got plans
to allow the Dover Harbour Board to come
along and to dredge this area to get
aggregate and sand in order for them to
build their new Harbor development so on
the one hand you want to protect this
place you want to build this incredible
marine conservation zone and yet on the
other hand you want to dig it up
protection must mean protection and the
same goes for your overseas territories
I talked about the South Sandwich
Islands which are just so very very
amazing they are incredible places they
are one of the most important
biodiversity hotspots on the entire
planet and yet less than 2% of the South
Sandwich Islands and the neighboring
South Georgia are actually fully
protected two percent I urge you to
fully protect the South Sandwich Islands
with just one stroke of the pen these
these islands are under British
jurisdiction with just one stroke of the
pen you could create a protected area
right now which has double the size of
the United Kingdom please you have to
stop thinking that you can sustainably
harvest an area that you can sustainably
manage an area and at the same time you
can also protect it you can't Britain I
urge you to set this area aside this
should be your gift to the world I now
want to end off by bringing this story
back here to this room to this
conference center to you here in
Birmingham what are all these stories
about ladies and gentlemen it is very
very clear to me that we have now
entered the era of big consequences our
environment is changing very very
quickly our environment now is right on
the edge Desmond Tutu a man which I love
who I love so very much
he always used to say that many of the
conflicts around the world are simply
conflicts over limited resources
when we damage our environments we
create conditions which are ripe for
conflict but when we protect our
environments we actually foster peace so
so many people come up to me and they
say well what can i as one person do to
try and save the environment well it's
very very clear that not one person can
fix the environment not one political
party can fix the environment and not
one country can fix the environments the
only way we're going to be able to solve
this problem is if all of us work
together the only way we're going to be
able to solve this problem is if we are
all talking to each other the only way
we're going to be able to solve this
problem is if we all build bridges I
urge you to do this this can be our
generations legacy ladies and gentlemen
thank you all very very much
[Applause]